hi I'm Eric Voss and the shield Legion
on FX is coming back for a second season
on April 3rd which we know from a new
trailer and a series of short terrifying
TV spots Oh keeping up the vibrant and
trippy imagery Legion is known for so as
we mentally prepare for season 2 let's
dive into this trailer point out a few
details you might've missed of course
most of these images are completely
bizarre and it's impossible to say what
they are without seeing them in the
context of an episode and honestly even
with the context of an episode that
usually doesn't make things any clearer
so let's just focus on the clues that do
kind of make sense and suss out the rest
of the details when the show comes back
shall we yeah we shall okay the first
detail that stood out to me was the
shadow king aka the devil with the
yellow eyes aka the angry boy in the
world I gave the dog King Hague a the
mental projection of Lennie it turns out
everybody got shot okay now at the end
of season one that shadow king escapes
David's mind by attaching itself to
Oliver with the man seen driving off
into the world with Lennie riding
shotgun now it looks like season two
will explore more of the shadow Kings
origin as Amahl Farouk with a new actor
playing him this is Navid makeup on if
you watch the show homeland he played
the shadowy terrorist Abu Nazir and if
you look closely at the reflection in
the sunglasses that looks like some
version of a devil with yellow eyes in
there reflecting his connection with the
demonic entity groups origin in the
comics was an Egyptian crime lord who
crossed paths with Charles Xavier
leading to a mental battle between the
two mutants that trapped Farouk in the
astral plane where he later latched on
to David Haller in this trailer there
are shots of Farooq emerging from some
egg-shaped pod as if being resurrected
by some ancient cult and now this
trailer suggests Farooq has evolved from
an internal threat to David's mind to an
external threat that is infecting all of
these characters there are various shots
of putana me and others convulsing with
their teeth chattering creepy there's
also something looks like a leaky inky
scorpion probably another David's bed as
he sleeps
Oh guys I just assume everything bad in
the show is a shadow king being an
[ __ ] now to counter this threat
Melanie bird's mutant forces have joined
Division three which appears to have
some very surreal design choices maybe
it's just me but I'm getting some
honeybee
vibes here this dude is wearing
something on his head that looks kind of
like a hive and then the walls of this
facility have a hexagonal pattern
everywhere all over the walls and the
window frames and all looks a lot like
honeycombs this could be suggesting
Division three is structured with a hive
mentality with like drones taking orders
from a queen of course this is assuming
this location is part of Division three
not some other plane of existence in
David's mind there's obviously a lot
going on here with new characters with
these like glowstick things around their
necks guys it's just really impossible
to help what's real on the show this
trailer also gives us a sense of what
happened to David since the end of
season 1 remember that season ended with
that post-credit scene showing David
being sucked into this weird drone thing
the shots of him and his grassy field
peering through a refracted eye hole
appear to be showing David on the inside
of that drone now according to
interviews season 2 will begin with a
time jump David will have been gone for
a year even though it won't it felt like
a year to him so Lots will have changed
in regards to his relationships with
Sydney and the others and we'll see
maybe this time jump will feature David
going deep into his mind to travel back
in time that could explain his visions
of Farouk in his original human form
actually notice what Farouk says here
who lives in the future you're going to
destroy and when you do she will cease
to exist I'm assuming Farouk is
referring to Sydney they're making me
think that David could be in the past in
this moment maybe facing an opportunity
to destroy a future timeline with Farouk
that would also destroy the people he
loves another cryptic figure I caught in
this trailer is this blind monk with the
two red lines on his forehead have you
looked closely David toggles over him
assuming this pose in the temple later
on we see the monk hovering with long
cords connected to his temples maybe
this is a new identity down and David's
subconscious that he's connecting to in
the wires or reflecting in some way
David's thoughts are being recorded but
we also see this figure lying beside
David on that giant number six I'm not
sure what the six refers to it could be
related to the six prongs on the basis
of these stands that are surrounding
them or maybe this monk is yet another
stage of Farooq's evolution into the
devil with the yellow eyes form I don't
know I guess he's kind of like the
Wartortle between that squirtle and
Blastoise and if you listen closely
during that first shot of the monk you
can hear David's name being whispered in
this model it's just snarl and before it
cuts to Clark and a different voice
whispering what do you hi
it almost sounds like Aubrey Plaza's
voice too spooky for me so let's move on
just like the first season it looks like
these episodes will pay homage to some
of the most iconic examples of
mind-bending cinema first there's this
shot that appears to be a nod to Alfred
Hitchcock's vertigo a camera even uses
Hitchcock's famous vertigo shot where
the camera pushes in on a dolly while
the lens zooms out making the viewer
feel literal vertigo vertigo is a
classic psychological mystery that uses
vibrant color grading and close-ups of
eyes imagery that's definitely baked
into the DNA of Legion there's also this
shot with Lenny flicking carries spoon
which reminds me a lot of the spoon
scene in The Matrix another movie with
false reality is an identity swapping
that we see in this show as well ensure
there's just lots of other bizarre
imagery that's probably too soon to try
to analyze but guys the best thing to
look forward to here more fancy
thankfully the Legion team realized that
the best parts of season one where the
choreographed dance numbers and they're
bringing us more in season two feel
closely these might even be taken from
different scenes David and Oliver's
moves appear to have matched the heavy
dubstep whereas Lenny looks like she's
part of some kind of jazzy Chicago style
burlesque dance either way we're dancing
on Legion what a question for you guys
do you need to understand Legion to
enjoy it where is this the kind of show
where the confusion and ambiguity is
just part of the fun I wouldn't know
your thoughts so comment down below or
tweet me directly at ei vas and probably
new rockstars on Twitter for updates on
our videos like and share this video and
subscribe to new rockstars for more
detailed analysis of superheroes stuff
shows like Westworld and Game of Thrones
and if you haven't already go watch my
analyses of season one I really turned
my brain into put in trying to explain
that insanity and if you really want to
help us grow you can contribute any
small amount to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our donors especially
mathletes all of us
thanks for watching guys bye bye